hello big
wow howdy how are you i love the energy
i love you
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood everybody
how are you doing you can't answer me
they're answering right in the comments
you hear them yes
oh well you will hear them in a second
because this episode we took your
voicemails again but first who do we
have today today we have tiffany and
jessica and nikki uh we are missing gina
but um she's here she's just this is
every once in a while you could tell
which episodes were filmed on the same
day yeah because she's not here
gina's not in this one block of episodes
she's not gone for this amount of it's
not like months that she didn't have a
burgundy or black outfit yeah so yeah
she didn't have a black she'd have
another black shirt to match gina
there's one thing about gina she doesn't
she doesn't like no blacks in her
wardrobe ever this is not gina's shirt
by the way
i did not pull this out of her closet
she literally did not
um well as i mentioned previously for
our 100th episode we had taken
voicemails from all of you and if you
want to submit your own voicemail you
can um come to our instagram because
every now and then we ask for
uh prompts and stuff from you so
sometimes it's um submissions via email
sometimes it's your dating profiles and
sometimes it's your voicemails because
we like to hear your pretty voice it
just makes it more real for us is what
we
realize is that you know talking into a
camera is one thing but then actually
like hearing from you and realizing like
oh they're like real individual peoples
out there listening uh is really nice
humans actual humans actually not just
human beings it made us emotional on our
last
voicemail episode if you want to go back
and
revisit it 100th episode um so in it we
said we would do another one and we are
and we asked this time if you would
leave us voicemails asking for either
advice if you ask us any advice question
or
something that you would think would
benefit other people to know like maybe
you have a piece of advice that you'd
like to share so we've selected some we
haven't listened to these yet we we read
google transcripts and they are
very very
like i just looked to see how long the
google transcript was and if it was
longer than a sentence i was like i
picked it i think
okay
that's a good criteria i just wanted
some something with some meat first
message
hello big
wow howdy how are you i love the energy
the dumbest of dumb guys and y'all have
taught me how to treat a woman very
above average i don't want to say i'm
the perfect guy
no we know we're not perfect you're man
just amazing you are entirely
perfect i just love y'all
how do i not give a damn
about negativity because it's kind of
hard not gonna lie not gonna lie
but um also to the audience maybe to
even me
uh i love y'all you're the kings and
queen
and i just y'all deserve the best
everybody deserves the best
um
all right that's it i love y'all
that's awesome
the energy i mean
he didn't even say his name i know he's
just like i'm a dumb dumb guy
little dumb guy we love you yeah i love
the energy yeah you're like glowing
through that voicemail yeah i just want
to be around you yeah um overcoming
negativity it's strange that you would
ask that question yeah
this what casey means when he says being
performative through something because i
wonder
if this guy is having so much energy
something's bothering him but he's like
kind of like i'm just gonna [ __ ] whoa
through it you know like [ __ ] it like
but it's really bothering him it's the
fake it till you make it energy i think
instead of the
i'm gonna be so fake and overcompensate
like i kind of feel that like where he's
he's trying to yeah he's trying to like
i don't want this [ __ ] to bother me yeah
this should bother me but it's kind of
[ __ ] bothering me yeah
i mean honor your feelings like let be
bothered sometimes that's what i wanted
to say just don't like project that
bothersome out to someone else like just
sit with it and like you know what
[ __ ] mad at that yeah she's just like
be bothered and then go but you know
what i'm moving on yeah like have it
have the cycle pass through which is
something i'm trying to learn because
yeah it's hard but but like being okay
with negative energy is i think key it's
like not letting it just don't want to
consume you yeah yeah that's used to the
hard part yeah i used to let it consume
me and then i would i would make sure
that other people knew that i was going
through something like i would have to
like complain about something
or like say some [ __ ] out loud and then
once i kind of stop doing that and i see
it in people like people in my family i
think that's where it comes from like
yes it's like that's your surroundings
well so like sometimes my dad will get
real pissed off about something and then
like he keeps
like for like 10 minutes like talking
about how that was so annoying or
something and i'm just like oh yeah you
know it's okay like whatever you know
like it's cool but then like you just
had like he just like wants to [ __ ]
like keep yeah it's bothering him so
much and then that's what i think maybe
this guy is like how do i not let
negativity maybe people around him are
so being so [ __ ] negative and he's
like how do i not let that bother me but
i think just understanding that when
when people are being negative it's
because they're hurting
for some reason
whether it's aggressive aggression
towards you
or just they're complaining too [ __ ]
much you can't deal with it like
whatever it is negative now
yeah it feels like it you've got to try
to turn into a bird with feathers that
water just slides off
uh listen or read eckhart tolle is a new
earth yeah he talks about the pain body
yeah and really that's what it is is
like it's some pain that they're that's
in them that they haven't dealt with
that they haven't healed from and so
they want to bring other people into it
because their pain body
their ego
feeds off of it it's like yes they
acknowledge more energy yeah and so
every time the ego goes away like when
it's satisfied and then the pain body
goes away they're in a good mood they're
a good person and then it's like wait we
need to be fed again
and so it just starts latching on to
things and that's really what other
people's negativity being projected on
you is is doing and then you're just
you know
letting it affect you
um but that's a hard one because being
on the internet i'm not gonna lie um as
much as you try to have thick skin and
you do have to have thick skin to be um
in a public eye
uh it still gets to you like you can
know exactly who you are and who you are
inside and you can say all the right
things to yourself like oh they're just
being mad because they're hurt or
whatever but it still hurts and
um because you're a human yeah you can't
understand why you deserve that yeah
negativity you know you're like what did
i why do i deserve that like what the
[ __ ] is this but it's not even about you
a lot of times someone else's negativity
is not even really about you probably
most of the time stepping back and being
an observer like if you were watching
that
negativity go on to someone else like
you're watching it happen to you instead
of being in you're just watching as an
observer and you'll like realizing how
silly it is like how it's like oh you
it's not about you you don't need to
take that on that's that's mostly what
eckhart tolls tolley's uh lesson is it's
like stepping away like kind of zooming
out outside of your body yeah even
outside of yourself
[Applause]
your consciousness is different you're
not your identity yeah like literally
like that's like just wrapping your head
around that part is [ __ ] mind-blowing
it's like you are an eternal being in
this temporary body you having a human
experience right yeah having a human
experience exactly and humans are
emotional creatures
and we're just like energy fields of
emotions bouncing off each other yeah
now we're all high look what you did
all right well you sound like a very
happy
person and that's also
a target for people who are unhappy oh
true yeah that they're like why do you
get to be happy [ __ ] you but also make
sure that you're being genuinely happy
because you could also be like avoiding
your own parents avoiding
that's why that was the first thing i
wanted to say was being okay with the
negativity is key because if you're just
like oh this is affecting me and i don't
want it to affect me like i want to
avoid it i want to run away to build up
inside you're is you're only going to
hurt yourself even more the body keeps
the score yeah girl preaches a great
book
we like to read on this show we read
yeah i don't know just as a final
thought i think everyone like gets to a
point sometimes where they just like i
don't want my life to be hard and it's
like it just doesn't work like that so
you have to get used to like the cycles
of like today's a bad day but then
tomorrow's going to be a good day today
this person was negative but maybe i'm
in control in some sort of way where i
can like fix it or get away from it or
just like nothing's permanent
everything's temporary every position in
life's temporary yeah and it's like mark
manson says like i think he's the one
that says like you just gotta pick which
oh yeah pick which people yeah
yeah pick this up everybody say what
you're willing to eat yeah pick your
problems
everyone has problems you're going to
have better problems and all you want to
do is keep upgrading your problems so
you have the better problems um also a
stoicism perspective of that is like um
do you hear about that farmer
the farmer story that's if the farmer
fable oh we're like um oh his prized
horse leaves and the town's like oh
that's terrible news and the farmer's
like maybe so and then the prized horse
comes back with a pack of wild horses so
he has all these
wild rare horses and everyone's like wow
what great luck and he's like maybe so
and then his son falls off one of the
wild horses while trying to train them
so they're like oh that's terrible he's
like maybe so and then because the son
was injured he didn't get drafted for
the war and they're like that's great
look and he's like maybe so it keeps
going on like that there's you don't
really know the labeling good and bad is
a misnomer it's just something that we
do to try to cope and it can build
because you're like all the bad things
happen to me or all the good things
happen to me or that person's lucky or
that yeah in a new earth eckhart has a
lot of those stories yeah where it's
really like insightful like just to see
like it things don't you don't know good
or bad exactly
all right well good luck with with your
journeys there with negativity
hey pretty ladies love you guys so much
i always listen to y'all at work uh miss
jessica you have a texan sister here
nice yeah
but
my question to y'all is regarding my dad
um he was my world and i held them up on
a pedestal but recently my mental health
has
really been struggling
just because my mom found out my dad has
been cheating on her oh no uh
uh oh did he get stuck and then really
tore our family apart
my parents have been married for over 30
years now and they had you know what
seemed like the perfect marriage
you know that one couple that matches
everywhere and everything together
that's literally what my parents were
like
but anyway i totally see my dad in a
different light now and
although they are working through it i
just can't get over it and obsess over
it all the time
uh every time he gets on his phone i
think is he texting that woman
or has he really cut ties with her
uh why did he do this yeah yeah
and it just kind of feels like i don't
know who this person is anymore
i'm really struggling to find some peace
with this whole
situation um
so i don't know should i just let it go
or can i just you know forgive and
forget or should i forgive and forget
um i'd love to hear your thoughts on
this
thanks for listening y'all wow that's a
tough one
yeah i i mean because
you should 1000 percent
honor your feelings you need a time to
process it i don't think making a
decision right now like i need to
forgive him he's going to be like
the best choice because you're feeling a
lot of things and you can't be right to
feel be fake to yourself
yeah you can't be fake that it doesn't
bother you or that you're just going to
let it go like you can't be fake and
also you can't deny the fact that now
you seem as a completely different
person because what it is i think and
this is not i'm not an expert in any of
this but um
i feel like our parents
are usually the people who show us
what relation how relationships operate
for good or for bad you know so if you
had parents that fought a lot your
version of what a romantic relationship
looks like are people that fight a lot
yeah and for you you saw your parents
are like the standard like the gold
standard like they are
loving they they're in love they are
romantically in love they are not sick
of each other they have what appears to
be the quote-unquote perfect
relationship so you learned through that
that you contain that you could have a
fairy book
love story and you went on with those
being your beliefs that you can find
true love and now what has happened is
that has been shattered that
that version of what they had
in your mind has been shattered but it
doesn't mean it's not real or true it
doesn't mean that you
yourself can't
find someone that's great that won't
cheat on you right i think that's maybe
what your your
subconsciously the disappointment about
yeah is that it took something so
ingrained in you something that you
loved that was beautiful and shattered
it i also think there's like a weird
thing like
the daughter's version of the father
and who she builds him up to be and who
she wants him to be
is never necessarily 100 who he really
is yeah right so like a man is a
is an entity among himself and like the
daughter's
imagination of who daddy is sometimes
doesn't take into account the dark side
of him or you know just different parts
of him like who he was before he was a
dad or there's just so much in that and
realizing that your dad is more of a
person than who you know
like he's
there's probably even more than just
this one bad thing he did there's
probably so much more about him he's
been alive for so many more years before
you were even a thought so like he's
i've been struggling with this sometimes
too i'm like wow like just really think
like my like who was my dad like [ __ ]
40 years like he's 70 almost i'm like
who was he i've only been alive for 30
years like who was he that whole time
before i was even in existence like
these are whole people with whole
thoughts and problems and issues and
like as a daughter you don't really ever
get inside of your dad's head exactly to
know like you could try to have
conversations with them he might be the
type that's not going to talk to you
about
fully what really happened or help you
get any type of
closure closure on this situation i
don't know how he is i hope that he
would be willing to talk to you about it
as a part of his amends but if he
doesn't yeah that's just
i definitely don't think you should try
to be fake with yourself but i also
don't feel like you have to let go of
like being the daughter to this father
that you love like maybe if you can try
to separate in your mind a little bit
like he is still dad he's still the man
he loves you yeah but then also he's
just a man he is a man he's just a man a
man i can't see her struggle yeah
definitely i mean this is a really
difficult situation because then she's
also
thinking of it from her mom's
perspective perspective she's like
looking at when she's on his phone all
the time like she's turning into like
the the girlfriend who's like are you
cheating again you know like yeah that's
tough i kind of relate a little bit to
that aspect of it um like with my own
dad for example like
you know the last time that we had a
conversation was our very first fight
and ever fight and probably ever because
he's been missing for a few years now
and like
like that that fight really knocked him
off the pedestal for me he's like i had
such respect for like so much respect
for him and then seeing like his real
flaws and like his his true identity or
like a different side of him that i had
never seen before just completely
shattered the image of him in my mind
and so that was really hard for me to
deal with and then also not having
closure either because of the fact that
now he's missing and i i can't really
repair that
but the part about being like the the
girlfriend part so like the fight that
we had was about his alcoholism like he
couldn't
he couldn't stay sober at the last time
that we saw him and that was something i
just couldn't understand and like i
couldn't empathize with the fact that he
had an addiction and like trying to
empathize like really try to understand
him so i was coming at it from like a
spoiled little kid where it's like but
dad you can't do this one thing for me
you know like
and and like trying to like catch him
like oh you're drinking again like
behind my back and like it just that's
what led to that argument because yeah
it was hard for me to see him as a
flawed person yeah and like a whole
person and
also like
whether or not you do understand how
addiction works it's almost like you
couldn't you couldn't connect the fact
that your dad
had that problem yeah so you're just
taking it maybe personal or something
like addiction doesn't really work like
that exactly like i just felt like do
you not love me enough yeah i put this
aside like it was coming from a very
selfish perspective
and channeling into that part where like
now i can't
trust him or like i wasn't able to trust
him for the rest of that trip and then i
didn't speak to him for a long time
and like even before he went missing and
yeah it's just like all that like
complicated emotions because i'm like
you know i thought you were better than
this and then like you really got
knocked down from the pedestal i got
really disappointed in seeing like who
you really are and like all this stuff
right
not anywhere near close to like her
situation but like a tiny little sliver
of like i can relate to that and it's
very um it's really complicated it's a
lot of mixed emotions because like
obviously she loves her dad obviously
she respects him in so many other
different aspects but then like
discovering that he's a completely
different person than from what you saw
and like what you knew
it really feels like being lied to i
mean because she said they were like his
mom like her mom and her dad would be
the type to like go out in matching
outfits and like be really cute and then
so that's just like it's like if steve
cheated on me yeah i would be like what
the [ __ ] because like he's just really
like never ever yeah like i've never
even had an inkling is it scary to know
that that's still possible like you've
only been married for this many years
about in another 20 years it could be
something happening it's something where
you feel like you he's the first guy
that's made me feel like i don't have to
worry about you yeah yeah yeah but her
mom felt the same way yeah about him
because they would he was so involved
yeah
yeah and it's like you always you don't
dream of a guy like that yeah that like
reciprocates love for you and would
never
do anything to be
unloyal to you or disloyal to you yeah
and then uh yeah i mean i i can feel all
your emotions in what you're going
through
through that voicemail because i'm
putting myself in your shoes and i don't
know
i don't know how i would feel like yeah
to see your dad that way and to have
that view shattered
is like
can you trust anyone then exactly
because if this like guy that was so
perfect and like someone that you would
always dream of getting is like still
flawed you're like man
you just have to roll the dice then i
guess yeah yeah i think
i'm sorry oh sorry um well i think a
thing that i feel coming up in me
feeling like if i could stand in her
shoes at all is like
how do i still
hold my because she's like she wants to
just like get it over with right like
should i just let it go should i just
whatever like because she just wants to
still
be cool with him and like have her dad
and like not be so worried about all
this [ __ ] but i think it's so it's okay
to have two things happen at the same
time that you're upset with him but that
you still love him and you can still
enjoy your time with because he's your
dad and he's not going to be here that
long it's not like your boyfriend that
you know you could just kick him to the
crib like this is your dad he's still a
very important person in your life
um he does need to like answer for what
he did or whatever but not to where like
you you can still be his daughter you
can still love him and then you can
still like work through this with the
family like you don't have to let it go
like but you can you know like at the
same time being mad you could still be
his daughter and like go out to dinner
and like whatever the [ __ ] you know like
still enjoy him yeah i hope that still
make an answer for it and still
yeah maybe it's too raw right now yeah
the conversation but i hope that one day
you guys are able to talk about it
one-on-one and maybe he can
like fill in those gaps for you yeah i
think that's the part that's just
shocking yeah earth-shattering shocking
like what the [ __ ] how does this even
happen maybe there's something that
there's no excuse for it but maybe he
can at least help you understand how he
got to that place exactly
kitty yeah he's giving you that yeah
yeah i hope i really hope that you get
some healing with that because that's
that's really
that's really heavy i recommend um maybe
speaking to a therapist about it because
it's such a like heavy
thing to go through especially to unpack
on your own and luckily i'm sure you
have your family that's also going
through it together but
i feel like uh like guidance from an
outside perspective a professional would
be really helpful yeah yeah because you
don't want to just eat it and like never
never really fully process it they can
give you some tools too because they've
they're really i mean that's what they
do is like yeah study all of that i love
that relationship stuff get a specialist
that specializes in
either relationships or
family yeah
family therapy
okay your mom is getting help too
because yeah shattering sending love and
healing to you
all right so now i want to take a quick
second to talk about ritual our sponsor
they have these amazing vitamins that
i'm a huge fan of i've been taking their
prenatals for a long time
absolutely love how my body completely
absorbs
these nutrients that they put in these
vitamins and you know what we deserve to
know what we're putting in our bodies
especially when it comes to something
that we take every single day
did you guys know that in women ages 19
to 50 there are over 97 percent that are
not getting enough vitamin d from their
diet dang that's like everybody and
exactly it's really important my
gynecologist was telling me like how
important getting that on track is that
it could lead to like like alzheimer's
memory loss all kinds of osteoporosis
like really bad stuff arthritis yeah oh
that bad stuff i almost said good stuff
all that bad stuff yeah you need vitamin
d also you need omega-3s because 95 of
these women are not or of us pretty much
because it's our age range uh we're not
getting our recommended daily intake of
key omega-3s
rituals essential for women 18 and over
multivitamin was formulated by extos
by exhaustive research to help fill
nutrient gaps in the diets of women ages
18 and up
and it was formulated with nutrients to
help support brain health bone health
blood health and provide antioxidant
support rituals committed to third-party
testing from usp and the non-gmo project
traceable and vegan-friendly ingredients
and always clear communication
no shady stuff at all ritual is offering
our listeners 10 off during your first
three months visit ritual.com big mood
and turn healthy habits into a ritual
that's 10 off at ritual.com big mood
don't forget ritual.com
big mood sometimes doing less can lead
to doing so much more actually
dipsy stories is a new company it's an
audio app they believe in less analyzing
and more feeling your feelings less
stressing more easing into things less
scrolling more savoring the moment less
pressure more pleasure pleasure yeah
dipsy stories is an app full of sexy
audio stories and now they have even
brand new written stories no matter who
you're into or what turns you're on
dipsy helps bring the stories to life
anytime anywhere no matter who you're
into or what turns you on dipsy helps
bring the stories to life anytime
anywhere close your eyes and let
yourself get lost in a world where only
good things happen and pleasure is your
only priority explore your fantasies in
a safe shame-free way there's hundreds
of stories to choose from and they
release new content every week so
there's always more to explore they also
have wellness sessions to help you wind
down and explore sleep sessions to help
you drift off for our listeners dipsy's
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to dipsystories.com
mood that's 30 days of full access for
free when you go to dipsy d-i-p-s-e-a
com stories.com mood dipsystories.com
moot all right next message
hello
this would be so crazy if you guys are
actually listening to this right they
are listening um is it crazy love you
guys have been
keeping up with you guys since i've gone
to jk films in like 2013 and now i'm
like more in college it's a long time um
don't do the math because i shouldn't
have been on the internet at that time
that young but anyways love you guys in
your individual activities and your
group activities but i wanted to ask you
guys a question about credit score
because i'm 19 so i've only had a credit
card and i only got a credit card
not too long ago okay so i think right
now the thing that might be weighing
down my score would be like
how little history i have because it's
only been like six months yeah
but i recently checked my fico score on
experian and i think it was 726.
[Music]
even though it says it's like good and
like close to very good i just don't
know how to gauge it
and like i don't really know what i'm
working towards in terms of where i want
my credit score to be i just assume i'd
want it higher
but like
where i hope for it to be and where i
should feel comfortable with it being in
at like what age because i'm just very
afraid that somehow i'll just completely
destroy my financial stability because
fortunately right now
i'm pretty stable which i'm very
grateful and blessed to have but yeah
any tips for
a
young adult just getting into the credit
game
and trying to make some good cash back
money
and
build a nice future for herself
um any advice would be very greatly
appreciated
um
although i i know i could probably also
just re-limit some of your financial
videos up again because those are also
really amazing so thank you for those
and all the
um financial advice things you guys have
done on your other
platforms and such because those were
really great resources for
me growing up
um yeah love you guys so much and i wish
you guys all the best
how cute oh gosh you're so young and
okay first how old did she say 19. yeah
the 19 year olds are so worried about
getting it right
i'm glad yes
you should have that i'd rather you be
scared yeah then be like everything's a
party yeah it's gonna be fun it's just
cute to see the generational change yeah
i don't think any of us gave a [ __ ] no i
didn't care and i got hard i got teased
for it yeah yeah everyone's got no one
and i'm like no i gotta study and then
all the kids now are like you
you're born in the wrong generation
um okay so
good for you you got a credit card as
soon as possible she's already got a 7
30 what yeah 7 20 something or something
like this
because i was worried that this was
going to go a different direction like i
wrapped myself
immediately and i was like oh no that's
usually the story yeah
because they don't teach you about your
credit
well we have more there's more resources
online now that's true which is great
i'm so glad that's available now
don't miss your payments
so don't use all your credit
line i think it's like thirty percent or
forty percent under twenty percent under
twenty percent yeah yeah so number one
because your credit's so new you're
you're correct that's why it's it's not
even low so it's weird because yeah so
anything over high
anything over 735 doesn't really matter
like honestly as far as getting approved
for loans and all that stuff it really
doesn't matter that much like you're not
saving a lot more um yeah it doesn't
make a big difference it's just a teeny
tiny difference but the bigger
difference is from like getting to 7 35
yeah exactly so you're already almost
there and you've only had credit for i
mean a year you can't possibly like you
can't add history that doesn't exist
like some things in life you just have
to wait for which is more about
maintaining
my biggest regrets
is closing my first credit card yeah
don't ever close that don't ever close
your credit don't take that first credit
and also i would recommend um opening
two more right now so because when you
open more later it's going to bring down
your average credit so it's going to be
like those years didn't exist
they take the average of how long the
history is so if you just open a brand
new one after five years well now your
average credit history is 2.5 years so
you want all of them kind of open around
the same time and now that you're at 7
26 you should be able to get approved
for two more no problem and they'll
probably give you a better uh limit and
more
perks like they're just better cards in
general because your first card's never
a really good card um that first card
will also probably increase your credit
limit as it's as you're being more
responsible with it and you've proved
it's basically like you just trying to
prove that you're a responsible human
being that's all it is um other things
if you buy a car so you get a loan on a
car and you're responsible with paying
that off every month
rent i don't know does student loans get
through student loans i've never had one
so no no yeah um so yeah student loans
rent doesn't go on your credit no it
doesn't work unless you don't pay it
then
so you don't get the positive it's only
a negative just pay it on time so you
don't like it so you do about wrecking
herself yeah
um it's very simple it's literally just
pay everything on time and to do that i
think how people get wrecked is when
they're like oh well i have a fifteen
thousand dollar credit limit and so they
spend as if they have fifteen thousand
dollars yeah don't do that that is not
what you have no you don't
just spend what you have things that you
would normally pay for in cash on your
credit card so your groceries your
utility bills like things that you
already you have the cash for and then
you pay it off every two weeks pay off
your balance every two weeks um you
could put an auto payment on
exactly yeah you don't pay interest and
every two weeks is when like the fico
score updates so you can do it auto and
pay your balance off every month and
that's fine but if you want to boost it
and not have it continuously go up up
and down a couple points then just pay
it off every two weeks and don't carry a
balance above 20
amongst all of your cards yeah so like
if you have 10 000 available
don't leave a balance of more than 2 000
right yeah exactly
and if you open two more credit cards um
just make sure that you put like
utilities on each of them so it's not
all on one card and then you're not
using two cards because they'll close it
if you don't use it mm-hmm you have to
prove on each card that you're like yeah
i never use them i have a credit card
with capital one and i never use it
and because i don't use it they also
won't increase my credit limit i've
asked i've been like can you give me
like a larger credit limit maybe then
i'll [ __ ] use this card and they're
like no you're not using it so we're not
gonna give you a higher i'm like oh this
card is so pointless but that was my
very first credit card don't ever close
it yeah yeah i'm not but like wells
fargo i think has given me the most
credit out of all of them i think
because i bank with them too but like
they freaking gave me you like every i
feel like every six months they give me
a couple thousand dollars
yeah i'm like [ __ ] i have a huge like
available credit at wells fargo does
that for me okay i don't even bank at
chase really yeah yeah so maybe figure
out which bank um
maybe there's forums or something where
you can see like who's who's willing to
give the most credit i feel like capital
one is a little stingy with their oh
yeah there's different like youtube
videos too of like the five best credit
cards to get yeah people do those all
the time every year there's new ones
it's probably hard to know who to listen
to though true graham stefan i will not
sponsor it but
i think he has ram sponsorship yes he
sponsors
he doesn't um no he has good updated
videos where he tells you all the
reasons why to get those cards i've
listened to him on a few credit cards
especially the amazon card i think gives
the best cash back rewards because they
give you five percent back on
purchase yeah i have amazon i have so
many reward points yeah so many times
like my my amazon purchase is paid by
itself because of the the awards
so it's actually the only card that i
really use the rewards for because i
have the amex platinum and that's
supposed to have like i mean it does it
has like a lot of great perks but i
never take advantage of them
they're
i only use the ones that are cash back
and then the cash just goes towards my
balance so i'm like i guess that was a
perk whatever it's like 50 off my
balance like i guess
well there's some like different ones do
different things so like if you're
really into travel there are like travel
ones where
if you instead of taking cash back
because they'll offer cash back but
instead of taking cash back you instead
spend it on travel they'll give you like
three times the amount of value
that i don't know because i i had the
venture card the capital one venture
card and that's supposed to be like for
traveling
i don't know what was happening because
i also wasn't like fully paying
attention so don't really like take what
i say with the cranes college graham
stefan oh yeah yeah do that because i
get i was getting like five times the
points or whatever for like a certain
amount of time and i'm like
where are these points like
how come i can't still like i've had
that camera
so many years i would use it a lot and i
couldn't [ __ ] book anything well like
i couldn't get a plane ticket where i'm
like this is [ __ ] i stopped using it
this is a bad review for capital
adventures yeah that's what i'm saying
where i'm like i don't believe them but
i got a lot of points on i don't know
what i was doing wrong
like we were doing something wrong maybe
not yeah i got a lot of points on my i
have a city card but it's through
american airlines yeah the airlines
yeah and i've got like 30 000 points
right now just sitting there and i
barely use that card so i use the travel
one with my chase the one that i said
was they keep increasing my credit limit
and um it's a business card though but
it's chase premier inc and
i heard that was a really good card it's
really good and i it's paid for so many
flights and so many hotel rooms i
haven't paid for travel in like i don't
know how long i mean because like yeah
technically have paid for it but not
really yeah yeah with the points yeah
just watch some go i mean i like also
you can go in like nerd wallet and trust
pilot yeah it's everything's dependent
on what you're like reviews but as far
as building your credit score goes it's
all about just maintaining that like hey
i'm responsible look at me spending look
at me paying it off every single day you
have to involve yourself in the process
so like and get different types of
credit so not only a credit card that's
one type of credit yeah a car loan is a
different type of credit a personal loan
like from upstart or like some of these
other ones that we've talked about
before um like actually i've taken those
out and paid them off and it but it
increased my credit score like i don't
even need it right like everything like
a five or ten thousand dollar personal
loan you take that out and you just pay
it off and my credit score went from
like 780 to 805 or something just just
because they want to see you play with
different types of credit maybe like
even if you don't need it what did you
end up doing with that i don't even know
what i didn't even use the money i just
took it out because i wanted to have a
different line of credit and then i
watched my score shoot up that's cool
they want you to like participate you
know yeah so
because i don't have a mortgage they
want you to be in the system exactly if
you get in the system and play the
[ __ ] game they'll reward you for it
yeah i did that because i didn't have a
mortgage like how do personal loans work
do you tell them what you're trying to
use it for like how does it yeah you say
like oh just uh refinance this or like
car alone or you just like make up
something or use it for what you
actually want to use it for like a lot
of times people will refinance credit
card debt with it
and so like if you have six
kind of consolidate you have like six
different credit cards and they each
have two thousand but you don't want to
make like four different payments every
month right you just make one payment
well the way i ended up doing that
consolidating my credit card debt was i
just moved um i paid off my credit cards
that had a high apr it was like
twenty-five percent they all really like
that like god damn yeah and so i just i
felt like i was drowning and that's how
they paid for the perks yeah yeah
so
what i ended up doing was um i put all
like i paid off all that debt from those
credit cards from a discover card where
it was like zero points yeah you can do
that too or i think i transferred it i
don't know yeah there's zero per apr
yeah
and i want another credit card how's my
debt like this because i wasn't drowning
in that apr anymore so that's how i was
able to consolidate myself yeah so if
you're already in debt that's how you
just don't get that deep but don't do
that just don't give up you just work on
paying your don't spend more than you
have yeah only spend how much cash you
have in the bank that you can cover
yourself with and then pay it off every
two weeks yeah you know what i don't
know who told me this but like how i
even got to that point of like having
like
a high credit
or not it wasn't even that high i it was
like seven thousand five thousand or
something but still um was because i had
heard that if i pay off my credit card
it doesn't build my credit what yeah i
haven't heard that from someone and so i
was like oh i always have to leave a
balance somehow and that's how i was
[ __ ] getting oh no like you don't
spend i was getting wrecked with the apr
because i was leaving
balance because i'm like oh yeah oh yeah
you got to work it out oh yeah it's a
great fine thing
if you don't spend on your credit then
it won't affect your credit score but um
if you
if you're leaving that's running that's
really bad yeah yeah yeah
because i don't know
you know what i will say i have maybe
you misconstrued this i don't know if it
was me but i have said before that i
found out when i was in a lot of debt
that if i paid all of that debt off
after it went into delinquency where it
already affected my credit card i was
already like four months behind on
everything back like when i was in my
20s and like really [ __ ] broke and i
could not pay for it um i found out
because i was like okay um i came out
into some cash like i owed ten thousand
dollars and i got five thousand dollars
in the bank and i was like okay i could
pay off half of my debt which sounded
terrible to me because like then i have
still oh five thousand dollars now i
have zero cash yeah but i was so i was
like how will that affect my credit
score because it's really really bad
right now and i wanted to go back up
because i had such a good credit score
and they're like it won't like once it's
in delinquency yeah there's no then it
doesn't even if you paid all of it
definitely don't [ __ ] pay it still
will take seven years for it to go very
seriously at that point you just let it
go yeah there's no really incentive like
once they mark you you're [ __ ] yeah
just gotta wait so i was like what's the
incentive oh well you might get sued if
you don't pay it yeah
not likely they won't sue you unless you
owe more than ten thousand dollars yeah
so it's not worth it it costs them too
much to see you if you owe like three
thousand dollars their legal fees are
going to be [ __ ] more than that dang
well with all like my credit card woes i
i luckily had never ever once missed the
payment that's good like i had always at
least paid minimum yeah
yeah so that's the one thing i was like
who told me i don't know that's that's
that's that's the bad advice
advice
like the worst but now so many people
have access to just type in like you
know how to use a credit card how to
build credit so i feel like they still
don't look into it like in a lot of
places if you're just not aware you just
think it's free money like i it shocked
me to hear that but um i think we had it
was joe like that joe takawa came on our
podcast our other podcast a couple years
ago and we talked about credit and he
said that his backstory was that he just
thought he had all this free money
and he would just spend it like it was
just like free money in the ether
and so he got into like massive amounts
of debt because he just didn't know yeah
that like that's how they get you is by
the interest rates and like that you're
never gonna pay it off yeah exactly and
he also i think lied about how much
income he was making so he could get
even more
of a limit and so he was literally
spending money you could never pay off i
think you could put that you make
literally anything as long as it doesn't
go over six figures so if you make fifty
thousand you could just say you make
seventy five thousand they don't really
check it like once you hit six figures
they're gonna be like we need a tax
return okay we don't believe you yeah
i'm like why what's the point of that
then they're not even going to double
check i think no no no one really knows
that that's weird
maybe because they're like well if
you're lying you're [ __ ] yourself
over here yeah you're going to be deep
and dead
like we want you to be in debt then they
don't want it to be so much debt that
then they never get yeah yeah yeah
that's true it's a balancing act all
right it sounds like you're doing well
though so good luck yeah you'll be fine
don't worry about it you're going to be
fine yeah keep listening to our podcast
though that's really what that's helping
you get that credit score i want to give
a shout out to noom because noom takes a
different approach to your health and
fitness goals that i feel like is much
more efficient
when i started trying doom i was like
holy
balls i do that i did not know that i
snacked that much because i always
thought i was a full meal eater but
guess what when you're bored when you're
stressed when you have anxiety and you
didn't even know you did things during
those bouts of time you are maybe
snacking on things and you are maybe out
adding to your caloric intake with empty
calories i eat a lot of
chicken snacks cheese snacks yes
generic cheese snacks snacks i ate a lot
of generics they will be chocolate and
cream cookies
yeah and so what noom does is they
really make you examine these things
like why are you doing these things or
can is there a way to break these things
maybe if you you if you
took the time to heal the psychological
aspects you could see results in other
areas of your life which is great not
just for health and fitness but for your
your mindset your mental state your your
habits reflect in your entire life yeah
exactly and you'll just start to notice
that more a healthier life doesn't mean
sticking to rules about what you can't
and can't eat it means having more
knowledge to build smarter more
sustainable habits noom uses a cognitive
behavioral approach that focuses on the
why instead of the what to help you
change your relationship with food and
everyone's journey looks different
you're not gonna look different don't
judge yourself by what your neighbor's
doing everybody has their own set of
problems and 75 of newm users actually
finish the program because they start
seeing results and they start seeing how
this different approach reacts
differently to their goals all you need
is ten minutes a day as well like i used
to think that you have to get up at six
o'clock in the morning and like do a
full last two hour workout the drastic
stuff doesn't last it doesn't and it
stresses your body a little bit actually
demotivates you yeah yes and that's what
gnome was telling me like hey maybe you
need to like reduce the stress
take a giant chill pill um noom has
published over 30 peer-reviewed
scientific journal articles so start
building better habits for healthier
long-term results sign up for your trial
today at noom noom.com
big mood that's n-o-o-m-dot-com
big mood to sign up for your trial today
have you ever pulled into your driveway
after a trip to the grocery store only
to realize you forgot the one key
ingredient you need for your dinner well
now you have options you can get the
groceries you need or a backup meal from
your favorite local restaurant delivered
with doordash get what you want right
now and right to your door you want late
night ice cream get it with doordash you
just want to stock up for the week while
you're busy working from home put in a
grocery order with doordash with over
300 000 partners you can support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
popeyes chipotle and cheesecake factory
ordering is easy your items will be left
safely outside your door when you choose
the contactless delivery drop-off
personally doordash is my favorite app
i've used all of them and i keep coming
back to doordash i love the user
interface all the door dashes in my city
are freaking great i suggest you try
doordash for a limited time our
listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code big mood that's 25
off up to a 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code big mood don't
forget use our code big mood for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply all right
next hey big mood hey
um i just wanted to say that i love you
guys so freaking much
um you guys have actually helped me so
much it's like crazy
um so i was in a very very abusive
relationship like it was so bad like i
don't know why i stayed
um it's not only like emotional
but like physical abuse like it was
crazy
uh like i didn't have any friends
he didn't let me talk to anyone he
didn't let me isolation literally tell
me to ask for permission to watch you
guys
oh wow did you watch anything oh man um
you know she would hate me and stuff uh
it's okay so
you guys seriously just made it a lot
easier to be
like i seriously don't know what the
heck i would do
if i didn't watch you guys because
it really made it easier like just like
think like you know what maybe this is
not worth it
um you know it was so hard to think
because
he was literally
all i had and i was alone i had no
friends
he made me cut off my freaking family
and yeah it was the most craziest thing
ever and you know i'm barely 19. wow i
didn't younger in my life i wasn't
having fun but um
you know i just finding love and
thanks to you guys i'm like free
i
i don't have any friends though i got
because that's connected to my family
thank god yeah um but you know i think
my life is finally getting on track
asking a question
how do you guys think
i can
fix my past friendships the past
relationships after this
break up because i'm pretty sure my
friends
at one best friend in particular i'm
pretty sure she freaking hates me
because when i
literally dropped her i
she was going through a lot and i
literally completely abandoned her
because of my abusive boyfriend
so what do you guys think i should do ah
thanks guys i love you so much
oh we love you yeah
first of all congrats for getting out of
that yeah
that's tough because it's it's like
psychological warfare and it's hard it's
hard to see past it yeah this is a
typical narcissist um this is what they
do is they they pray one they pray on
weaker
no
no that's that's uh yeah that's a bad
word no yeah because it's actually they
pray on strong women yeah and they kind
of find joy in breaking them down and
getting them to be uh compliant that's
the part of the game yeah that's part of
the game because it's not a challenge if
it's just some like you know but some
but if you don't know that then you're
kind of naive like if you don't know the
yeah naive is a better term for it no
it's not weakness it's you're not a weak
person it's just um yeah they they prey
on people who are
uh
trusting and uh
are giving and
that they can they can slowly they i bet
they love bomb do in the beginning and
they they made you feel really special
like they don't like anybody they like
you
and uh they kind of gave you some omaha
maybe you could fix this and this to
help you work on yourself create a
codependency yeah create that
codependency and then
slowly like you get you don't even know
you're getting wrapped in that web and
they've convinced you that they like
they love you and they're all doing this
for you and like they're giving you some
solid advice you need to drop those
friends they are bad for you and they
try to isolate you so you don't get any
outside perspective that's why he wanted
to ask permission to watch shows because
he doesn't want you to have any outside
insights
or
perspectives or anything that's going to
sway you any other direction but he does
not like me
he's like that [ __ ] no you could not
watch that [ __ ]
um so yeah it's hard to break that so
good for you for getting out and it will
take some healing for you to
come back to a place um i think that
the question was about repairing
relationships um
especially with that one particular
friend yeah like how she says like she
feels bad because she dropped her while
she was going through so much
i i can see like how that's really
like it puts you in a place where you're
like [ __ ] i [ __ ] up so hard like would
they even take me back but also i think
have some grace with yourself because
you are going through some crazy [ __ ]
yourself you know like i'm sure your
friend can understand that level of like
well you know you got isolated you were
in a very physically abusive
relationship emotionally abusive
relationship so like i'm sure depending
on like the type of person that this
particular friend is like they sh
a a reasonable person would be
understanding
of that situation the kind of friends
that you want in your life are the kind
of friends that when you come and say
look i don't know what the [ __ ] was
going on i don't know how i got in that
situation i'm i regret dropping you i
regret like and you can say sorry yeah
yeah i apologize and then understanding
like if she doesn't
want to be your friend even after
explaining like i'm so sorry like this
is what i was going through i was not a
good friend but i you mean so much to me
if she like if like if she still doesn't
want to be your friend then like maybe
it's just not a good match but yeah so
you're 19 like
your life is not even so it hasn't even
started yet
your life hasn't even started i know
when you're like you're 19 and 20 21 you
think like you're so old you're not an
adult you're not you're into your life
but you have like 50 more [ __ ] solid
years of life and that's like way longer
than you've even been alive
take this decade to make all the
mistakes
yeah like you're gonna make new friends
like just stay out of her don't even get
into a relationship right now take a
full year if you can't afford some sort
of therapy get that take at least a year
of not being in a relationship to work
on yourself try to find your friends
yeah you need to make friends first and
if it's not the ones that you lost
that's okay like i don't even talk to
the people that i was friends with when
i was 19. so you don't expect that these
people that you lost are going to be the
only i know that you love them so i'm
not saying they don't matter but don't
expect that like they're
supposed to be in your life forever
because you know friends come and go
anyway and that's okay and timing is
everything yeah yeah and i just think
that right now you really need to build
your who you are like your inner
stability your core of who you are back
up because that's really what they take
away from you and abusive relationships
is like you don't even know who you are
or if you you question your ability to
make decisions on your own
you question a lot of your
like of yourself like your judgments and
because that's how they make you think
is that you are not able to think
without them not only that but then
going through such
like such abuse you end up shaming
yourself yeah you're like how could i
get something yeah yeah and then like
you that's what i'm saying you have to
give yourself grace because it really
starts from within you like you loving
you is the starting point like that's it
like you have to be able to forgive
yourself from for going through that if
you're blaming yourself
and like just finding a path to move
forward and
yeah definitely seeking therapy again
like that that would definitely benefit
you so much um yeah it could take some
time like of your friends seeing that
the relationship is over you're no
longer under his grasp you know maybe it
takes a year that your friends are going
to be like okay i think she's
like we we feel safe enough to allow her
back in yeah she's not going to hurt us
yeah like she's created a stable
environment for herself now i feel safe
enough to allow her back in my heart
like maybe your friends just need time
like because they were hurt and that's
okay like everyone just needs time like
time does heal
yeah and you know action also like what
are you doing now to like create
stability in your life like what are you
going to do to make sure that you don't
you know
fall for this type of thing like you
need to educate yourself you need to
have therapy you need to work on like
what do you want your day to day to look
like and not be have anything to do with
relationships right now you need to be
solid and breaking patterns right that
like attract those type of people yeah i
mean you already got out which is more
than we can say for a lot of people so
congratulate yourself like really deeply
congratulations huge yeah it's really
huge and and even though it was like a
horrible shitty
bad situation
um i think it's
pretty healthy to view your experience
as
something that
even though it's like horrific right the
fact that now you're on the other side
of it like you can get that experience
and learn from it and grow from it and
become an even better more educated
person because of that experience
instead of having that weigh you down
and like
and say like well great like now i don't
have any friends and now i'm stuck in
this hole because of that situation i
was in because i've lived in that victim
mentality
my whole life and it literally doesn't
help you at all it keeps you in that
hole forever there's something that
that's i think there's a statistic that
women that have been in physically
abusive relationships find their way
back to another one it'll be it's the
same situation it's a different person
that's my story yeah that's my story
that doesn't have to be your story
that's why therapy is highly recommended
and no relationships i'm [ __ ] telling
you don't get into another relationship
don't even be like well this one's not
like the last year no no no no
you don't know that yeah yeah you're not
stable enough to know that you really
need to build this foundation first in
yourself before so you're like a rock
that can't be swayed yeah
yeah well good luck
congrats
yeah
good luck we love you we have time for
one more but we will be doing this in
the future so if you want this is fun
yeah if you want to call it it is fun to
hear people i love it i love hearing
everyone and i i like feel your energies
like different flavors yeah
you can feel their personalities through
their voice yeah like sense who they are
just for like the tiny little snippet
and like connect with you guys through
your voice i love it i love it too okay
last one but follow our instagram if you
want to participate in future episodes
hey so i just wanted to say that i love
you all so much i've been a fan since
day one of y'all's podcast
um i just wanted to ask you a question
and for more context i'm 22
and i'm getting ready to graduate
college and
become an adult and things like that and
my question is how did you guys deal
with the uncertainty of whether or not
you'll make it in your career
and just how did you guys deal with the
overall transition of becoming an adult
as a whole because it's definitely very
scary to me not knowing
like a definitive answer of whether or
not i'll be successful in the future
thank you guys i love you all
we love you
it's a very fair question and a concern
a very common question i feel like i'm
gonna throw it to jess because this is
like a
i feel like you've had your own
struggles with this of needing of
wanting certainty i feel like we had
talked about this in a different point
in time and what was i saying i think i
was saying something like everyone feels
like they need to know
what's gonna happen but you're not it's
not possible like you have to just keep
trying things right like i think that's
what the the general kind of advice for
that question typically is is like no
one [ __ ] knows no one has any
certainty that's not how life works
there's no job guarantees nothing
anything yeah you just have to keep
doing either allow that to scare you for
the rest of your life knowing that it's
never going to be certain or just
embrace it except that like nobody knows
and therefore the world's your oyster
just put one foot in front of the other
yeah and try things and fail and learn
from it and and get better and improve
and like study your growth and and your
progress and add good habits to your
life and that keep you progressing and
you're going to have setbacks um that's
one thing that you could know for
certain is there will always be setbacks
and things are going to go the way you
think highs and lows just keep game
planning reassessing awesome things
take a good look at your own definition
of what success means yeah i was just
thinking
and why yeah why is that successful like
is it having lots of money in a big
house
or is it having like uh really rich and
fulfilling friendship circle or more
free time
like what is success what matters to you
that will help you like create a road
map yeah yeah because i was actually
just talking to one of my cousins about
this because she was
she's kind of on this path where she's
just like i don't think i really want to
work like i'd rather like have more free
time to like do the things i love like
than my hobbies and this and that and
she like watches i was kind of trolling
her a little bit because she sent me a
video over text of i think it was warren
buffett and he was like yeah you know i
would trade places with you know people
who don't have the kind of money i have
like we basically eat the same food we
basically wear the same clothes we
basically drive the same car
and warren buffett right and then he's
like the only thing like i can travel
better i can hop on a private jet
there's certain things there's options
and freedoms
but he was like at the same time like
we're both still generally kind of the
same people like our lives aren't that
dramatically different just because i
have a billion and you have like 50 000
which and i trolled her and i was like
rich people are always trying to tell
you not to be worried about being rich
they don't want you to [ __ ] think
that you know or focus on how they're
hoarding all the money but anyway um
just decide like what lifestyle you're
gonna be okay with because you can't
necessarily have it all so like for my
cousin she's okay with having less money
but like having more free time like
she'll she can do van life or she can do
whatever the [ __ ] but for me
i'm
i'm more happy like
i feel like okay so let me preface it by
saying this everything's gonna be a [ __ ]
sandwich right so like either you're
gonna be struggling and not have as much
money and there's gonna be things you're
gonna have to do without there's gonna
be things that you wish you could have
or maybe you're gonna work a lot more
and have more money but then the
struggle there is that you have less
free time and like so you're trading
your life for something
you know whether it's like
uncertainty or possibly not knowing if
you're gonna make ends meet or it's you
can make ends meet you have an excess of
things but you have you're lacking in
time or whatever so you have to just
decide which road you want to take and
like you may not
know that right away like you can try
the corporate nine to five thing and to
where you'll have excess money but less
time or you can try the [ __ ] van life
thing where you have not enough money
but tons of free time to do activities
and like decide what works for you like
i started i went to college i started
corporate life i left it came into this
for six years and then when i went right
back to it so you don't also have to
stay on the road that you decide either
yeah and i agree with that i also would
add to that that
you don't have to pick one forever if
you're smart about it you can if you
start investing young which if you
you're very young already if you start
now just putting aside like 500 bucks a
month
and put it into some solid investments
that get you a 10 or greater roi per
year you have a compounding interest
effect where you can choose like where
okay i'm going to work a lot and i won't
have a lot of free time but as that
compounds i'll soon have more i'll have
financial freedom that buys me that time
and i don't have to work it won't equate
the number of hours i work won't equate
directly to how much money i'm making
and over the years you start getting
more and more freedom or if it was the
other way around and you traded more
time for less money still putting that
away you'll have more money in the
future where you don't have to pick
between the two roads and and that's
kind of like the game is
is starting young and letting compound
interest work in your favor and making
smart investment choices instead of
spending your money for frivolously
frivolously there's also something to be
said like you're only young once right
and you only have like the energy you're
gonna have once your youth your beauty
like all of these things so also there's
some people that maybe just may take
their first 30 years
not really doing anything at all worth
like monetary value not investing at all
or whatever
but then they have all these rich
experiences that they got and then maybe
they'd like [ __ ] get on and get to
work in their 30s and that's okay too
like there's different things you can do
because you could also
burn your whole 20s out
investing saving every penny not
enjoying not taking anything oh yes
for sure
accidentally
at 32. you know what i mean yeah you
could have done all of that like
thinking oh i'm just going to retire at
age 45.
experiences for yeah
work week by tim ferriss he talks
exactly about this that um you can
basically have a million dollar
lifestyle with a 30 000 budget because
of what your definition of success is
like being able to travel like putting
it all into
putting your work into four hours a week
but it's it's done efficiently and
effectively oops sorry um where you can
travel and do it remotely and have all
these experiences and have an enriched
life while you're you know living but
doesn't have to cost a lot of money
because it talks about how like everyone
saves for retirement but those are your
like worst years yeah you're [ __ ]
decrepit then yeah don't do that instead
take all these mini retirement
retirements where you're like living
your best life like all the things you
want to do at the end but you're doing
it now and you're just doing it smarter
yeah it's really interesting everyone
wants an answer to life though yeah yeah
like there is no answer there's no one
right way yeah and like going back to
her part about like how do you cope with
like the uncertainty of your future
you can see like it's really your
perspective because
for me like i totally get that whole
like fear about like oh my god my career
like even like right now like i'm 32.
that's never [ __ ] i don't know what to
do
i i get that but it's also you can view
it at from a different perspective where
it's like cool like i don't know where
i'm going like i can literally just do
whatever it is that the next the next uh
opportunity that arises can take me this
way or that way or whatever you don't
need to know
exactly where you're going it is good to
have like a guidance plan yeah and a
plan for sure that's all that's in your
control you are not in control of
anything else and i was also reading
something about uh that put a great
perspective on it was that like nothing
is certain right like or permanent you
wouldn't want it to be though because
it's so boring imagine if you knew
already how your entire life was going
to go that's so boring and not just that
but like stressing out to the max to
make sure that that's the plan that
you're you're following like like those
people that are just like meticulously
planning every single detail of their
life because by the time they reach this
age they have to get to this point and
they have to do this and achieve that
and create so much depression you forget
what you even did it for you're not
living you're hitting the milestones but
you're not exactly you lost the life
part of it yeah because you needed that
to hit exactly how you planned it in
your head just let go a little bit of
the plan anxiety always balance like you
don't want to be too like i don't have a
plan but you don't also want to be like
so rigid that you're not open to like
experiences that you could be having and
that's all it is it's like just go out
there and have fun put one foot in front
of the other and um
have gratitude for your experiences even
the failures that you're learning from
and uh
you'll do fine don't stress girl you got
it yeah i got that view of my head one
day at a time the dog drinking the
coffee with the fire like yeah it's fine
yeah that's fine everything's fine
nothing's ever gonna feel that great
honestly like it's just everything's
hard all the time don't watch the news
the news will tell you that the world's
never fine ever never because it's never
going to be fine it never has been fine
that's how they keep readers yeah yeah
yeah
all right guys well thank you for so
much for submitting your voicemails and
calling in if you want to participate in
future episodes of this or if you'd like
well let us know if you want more
episodes of this and then if you want to
participate follow us at big mood girls
on instagram yeah check out our sponsors
and also i guess you could go follow
gina and just even though she's not here
yeah but like the phone number here call
it yes more voicemails i hope this
helped like
we're not experts at any of this i think
i think the main takeaway is that nobody
knows yeah we're in our middle 30s early
30s we still [ __ ] know half the [ __ ]
we just got to check out as much
guidance as we can based on our own
experiences but even then there's no
definitive answers out there
nothing is a guarantee so
with that in mind go have fun out there
guys like have fun you're you could die
tomorrow just trying to enjoy just just
try to enjoy it today
you could die tomorrow
we love you bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you